good afternoon with the holiday season
fast approaching we want to take a
moment to address some online threats
that could make the internet an unsafe
place as the year draws to a close
for most of us the holidays means
spending time with families so it's
important then families know what they
should post on our Facebook nothing
under no circumstances should you post
anything to our Facebook families uncle
Roy I'm not politically active
especially not on Facebook and
especially not for you-know-who mom I
know that's a cute picture of me that's
why I posted it you don't need to remind
all my friends aunt Carol I promise I
have seen every single baby hippo video
seriously so much it would destroy you
Kurt I know you're my cousin all but
please stop hitting on my friends
they're not gonna be sure to chill when
you visit you all have my number you
have my email maybe send it just to me
it's not that I'm embarrassed it's like
it's just sometimes I'd rather keep it
in the family exactly keep it in the
family which is why we're starting the
hashtag hashtag keep it in the family to
help your family when they say something
and I mean anything on your Facebook
gently remind them hashtag keep it in
the family and together we can have a
safe and private holiday season thank
you